find the probability of rolling doubles
on Tucson two six-sided dice numbered
from 1 to 6 so when they're talking
about rolling doubles they're just
saying if I roll the two dice I get the
same number on the top of both so for
example a 1 and a 1 that's doubles 2 and
a 2 that is doubles a 3 and a 3 a 4 and
a 4 or 5 and a 5 a 6 and a 6
all of those are instances of doubles so
the event in question is rolling doubles
on two six-sided dice numbered from 1 to
6 so let's think about all of the
possible outcomes or another way to
think about it let's think about the
sample space here so what can we roll on
the first die so let me write this as
die die number 1 what are the possible
rolls well they're numbered from 1 to 6
it's a six-sided die so I can get a 1 a
2 a 3 a 4 a 5 or 6 now let's think about
the second die so die number 2 well
exact same thing I could get a 1 a 2 a 3
a 4 a 5 or a 6 now given these possible
outcomes for each of the die we can now
think of the outcomes for both die so
for example in this in this let me draw
a grid here just to make it a little bit
neater so we draw a line there and then
a line right over there
let me draw actually several of these
just so that we can really do this a
little bit clearer so let me draw is let
me draw a full grid all right and then
let me draw the vertical lines vertical
lines only a few more left there we go
now all of this this top row these are
the outcomes where I roll a 1 on the
first die so I roll a 1 on the first die
these are all of those outcomes and this
would be I run a 1 on the second die but
I'll fill that in later these are all
the outcome for our role of 2 on the
first die a 2 on the first die this is
where I roll 3 on the first die
on the first i4 i think you get the idea
on the first die and then a five on the
first die five and then finally these
are this row this last row is all the
outcomes where our role is six on the
first to die
now we can go through the columns and
this first column is where we roll a 1
on the second die a 1 on the second die
this is where we roll a 2 on the second
die so let's draw that out and write it
out fill in the chart here's where we
roll a 3 on the second die 3 3 this is a
comma that I'm doing between the two
numbers here's where we have a 4 here's
where we have a 4 a 4 and then here's
where we roll a 5 on the second die just
filling this in filling this in almost
this last column is where we roll a 6 on
the second die 6 on the second die 6 on
the second die now every one of these
represents a possible outcome this
outcome is where we roll a 1 on the
first die no 1 on the second die this
outcome is where we roll a 3 on the
first die 2 on the second die this
outcome is where we roll a 4 on the
first die and a 5 on the second die and
you can see here there are 36 possible
outcomes six times six possible outcomes
now with this out of the way how many
how many of these outcomes satisfy our
criteria satisfy the criteria of rolling
doubles on two six-sided dice how many
of these outcomes are essentially
described by our event well we see them
right here doubles well that's rolling a
1 and a 1 it's a 2 and a 2 a 3 and a 3
of 4 and a 4 a 5 and a 5 and a 6 and a 6
so we have one two three four five six
events satisfy this event are or are the
outcomes that are consistent with this
event
now given that what it let's answer our
question
what is the probability of rolling
doubles on two six-sided die numbered
from 1 to 6 well the probability is
going to be equal to is going to be
equal to the number of outcomes that
satisfy our criteria or the number of
outcomes for this event which are 6 we
just figure that out over the total I
want to do that pink color over the
total number of outcomes over the size
of our sample space so this right over
here we have 36 total outcomes so we
have 36 36 outcomes and if you simplify
this 6 over 36 is the same thing as 1/6
so the probability of rolling doubles on
two six-sided dice numbered from 1 to 6
is 1/6